you know one of my favorite
inspirational quotes is you can't take
the elevator to success you have to take
the stairs and so watch out success here
I come
fYI I am legally obligated to tell you
that I am in no way a certified life
coach but I plan on taking night classes
oh look at this it's gonna take this
lady a long time to find success maybe
she should take the elevator I'm 78
asshole gotta take any opportunity you
can to get a good foot blast 1 2 3
somebody say quick feet
ah yes baby well it's been a great warm
up but I'm sure ready to get the real
workout started right oh that's bone
hey guys had a minor accident but hey
guess what like my mom said when I was
born there are no accidents just
challenges
oh so full of scenic ahead Oh Jimmy sir
how much further is it to the top ma'am
you're bleeding
gross an econ email a lot of people take
breaks but sometimes life doesn't allow
for breaks quick break I got
athletically induced asthma hey Mexican
pizza for lunch
Oh how do you just look at this view so
chill Oh move it you little twit this is
your snapchat life coach rocky reminding
you to never give up
just say hashtag blessed
you